hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
una jornada cada año recuerda la
situación de los refugiados en el mundo
la última década confirma incrementos
nunca antes reportados de quienes huyen
de sus hogares en busca de protección
uno de cada 88 habitantes de la tierra
abandonaron sus casas en 2021 una cifra
que sumada a la reportada en 2022 ya
supera los 100 millones de desplazados
forzosos la guerra en ucrania agravó
esta tendencia global pero acnur llama a
no olvidar la multitud de emergencias
humanitarias y guerras latentes en
varias naciones del sur global marina
sardenya tiene los detalles en el
siguiente reporte
una tragedia que no cesa con el paso de
los años se incrementa el número de
personas forzadas a dejar sus hogares el
último informe de la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados señala que 2021 al
menos 89 tres millones de personas se
vieron obligadas a huir de sus lugares
de origen por la violencia los
conflictos armados las relaciones de
derechos humanos o las múltiples crisis
económicas sociales o climáticas sin
embargo en 2022 se supera el récord de
más de 100 millones de personas debido
al desplazamiento masivo por la guerra
en ucrania que ha relegado a un segundo
plano otras emergencias humanitarias
gobiernan recuerden que ahora todos
estamos muy centrados en ucrania pero
ucrania viene después de una línea de
otras emergencias tuvimos a etiopía diop
ya tuvimos la situación en afganistán en
particular we had the bank of en
particular tuvimos un montón de crisis
no resueltas que explican gran parte de
los desplazamientos que seguimos
reportando displays puente to y continue
to reports de estas personas de interés
para acnur 27,1 millones son refugiados
53,2 son desplazados internos y 4,6
solicitantes de asilo un 11 por ciento
más que el año el 69 de los desplazados
en el extranjero proceden de sólo cinco
países siria venezuela afganistán sudan
del sur y mianmar según el reporte del
organismo los menores representan el 41%
del total de la población desplazada a
la fuerza en cuanto al género 27% son
hombres y el 25% mujeres a propósito del
día mundial del refugiado que se celebra
cada 20 de junio acnur hace hincapié en
los países de acogida de estas personas
el 83% están acogidas en países de renta
baja y media y los países más
empobrecidos otorgaron asilo al 27 por
ciento del total de solicitantes por lo
que ahora hacen un llamado a las
naciones del norte global para agilizar
la acogida de estas personas así como
garantizar condiciones de vida dignas en
las naciones receptoras
en américa latina méxico registró en
2021 más de 130.000 solicitudes de asilo
lo que corresponde a la tercera cantidad
más alta del mundo de acuerdo con acnur
tapachula la ciudad que más recibe
peticiones de centroamericanos nuestros
corresponsales andrés suárez jaramillo y
aurora vallado nos cuentan la historia
de un hondureño que escapó de la
violencia en su país y ahora espera que
las autoridades mexicanas le otorguen
refugio para iniciar una nueva vida
lo conocieron en el camino y lo apodaron
bob marley su nombre real es marcos
amador y es un hondureño que escapó de
su país el pasado 8 de junio para evitar
que las maras reclutarán a su hijo axel
para adelante para atrás de pagar en
porfa baja a mi hijo
lo quería meter a la mala fuerza y la
verdad las cosas que nosotros siempre
hemos sido personas honradas honestas y
trabajadoras y no acepto eso iba para él
tras salir de honduras marcos y axel
cruzaron guatemala en autobuses hasta
arribar al albergue el buen pastor en
tapachula
[Música]
cuando se siente bien ya salir de su
país porque sabiendo que está peligroso
el país jon morse viene a emigrar aquí
también porque es un poco difícil pasar
lo que no ha pasado
porque hay algo no quieren que uno se
meta pandillas y uno no quiere eso
porque uno quiere un futuro para su vida
marcos y axel tienen dos opciones para
cumplir su meta de llegar a eeuu esperar
meses mientras se tramita una visa
humanitaria que le otorgue estatus legal
de refugiado o aventurarse en una
caravana de miles de migrantes con la
cual evite ser aprehendido por las
autoridades de inmigración y ser
eventualmente deportado
marcos le apuesta al trámite de la visa
humanitaria sin importar que el proceso
se demore hasta seis meses en dar frente
a los acostamos a las dos los levantamos
a las tres de la mañana y armamos
nuestro grupo que traemos y los vendimos
caminando que los vengan con los papeles
para cruzar para el otro lado porque esa
es la idea
las solicitudes de asilo en méxico las
otorga la comisión de ayuda para los
refugiados comar un organismo que de las
130.000 peticiones que recibió en 2021
sólo pudo tramitar 38 mil menos del 30
por ciento por lo que para marcos y su
hijo gran parte del sueño americano
dependerá de la suerte
en la actualidad del desplazamiento en
el mundo supera las soluciones
disponibles durante la última década los
nuevos conflictos obligan a miles a huir
y el reto está en los países receptores
pero la paz podría significar el retorno
y el dato de migración de la semana de
los millones de desplazados dentro y
fuera de las fronteras de sus países
5.7 millones lograron retornar a sus
hogares en 2021 volvieron 5,3 millones
de desplazados internos y 429 1300
personas refugiadas
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes efe 24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]